Okay, so time to start. So let me
begin by reviewing a little bit, uh,
the dynamic hedging,
which I could have described a
little bit more clearly last time.
It's a very important idea and I
made a little bit of a mess of it.
So let's say,
or I didn't make that big a mess of it,
but a little bit of a
mess of it. So let's, uh,
be a little bit careful now about
who knows what and what you're doing.
So we said,
imagine somebody who knows
that the probability the
Yankees are going to win the
world series is 60% and therefore the,
again,
each game of the world series
or 60% and knows that if he,
the probability the Phillies
win the game is 40%.
So suppose that he find somebody who's
willing to bet with him on the Phillies
so he can win $100.
If the Yankees wins,
he has to pay $100 of the Yankees lose.
Now his expected payoff is 20.
He should take the bat.
Because if the person's willing to bet on,
even at even odds,
the Phillies fans willing to bend it,
even odds, and he knows the odds are 60,
40 an expectation, he's going to make
20. So it's clear what he should do.
But the problem is he subject to risk.
And He,
although he's right about the odds,
he could still through,
even though he's done the smart thing,
he could still end up losing $100,
which could be a disaster for him.
So we we'd like to do is to hedge his
bets. And what does it mean hedges?
Bet.
Well,
suppose there was another bookie
who was willing to bet at 60,
40 odds in either direction,
then what should he do? Well,
if he could find another bookie who
was willing to bet at 60 40 odds,
he should try and lock in
a $60 $20 no matter what.
So he should, um, do this bet.
He should bet with the other bookie $80.
Uh,
he'd be willing to give up $80 if the
Yankees won in order to win a $120 if the
Phillies win. And that's a fair bet.
According to the other book, he,
because it's 60, 40 odds, 60% of
this and 40% of that or you know,
this is three to two odds. So it's a,
it's a fair bet. So in other words,
he makes money by taking advantage of
the Philly fan to bet on the Hankies,
but that subjects them to whip to risk.
So in order to minimize
the risk he hedges is bat.
That's where the expression came from.
He hedges that bat by betting in the
opposite direction on betting on the
Phillies with his bookie in the
opposite direction. But you know,
standing to lose less than he,
you know,
he's betting in this proportion and
this amount so that he gets 20 no matter
what. So He's locked in his $20 profit.
Okay, so that was where we began.
Now let's just think about it a little
bit more carefully than I did before.
Somebody fact basically
asked this question,
is he really making money?
Because he understands better the
odds of the Yankees winning the game?
Is he making money? Because
he knows the odds are 60, 40,
and the poor Philly fan thinks
they're 50 50. The answer is no.
That's not why he's making money.
Doesn't matter what the odds
are of the Yankees winning,
he's winning because he's
managed to arbitrage,
to different betters, namely the
Philly fan and the other bookie.
And the fact that they
differ in their beliefs.
The fact that he can trade with
the bookie at three to two odds,
whatever bet he he wants.
And the Philly fan is a trading
at different odds with him.
That's what enables
him to make his profit.
So how did he make the arbitrage?
So what is an arbitrage?
An arbitrage as you find two bets,
uh,
which are more or less the same thing,
which in fact are exactly the same thing,
but trade at a different price.
Okay. So what are the, uh,
what are the two bets? Well,
there's the Philly Bat,
the Philly Fan bet,
and then there's the bookie bat
plus borrowing $20
okay.
So if he's going to make 20 for sure.
So he could make the 20 at the beginning
just by borrowing against his winnings.
Then he'd have 20 at the very
beginning and his payoffs would, uh,
you know,
would be it.
The payoffs from the Philly fan
bet would be exactly. He'd over 20,
so he'd have minus a hundred,
you know, so this bat is a,
he'd get 20 at the beginning.
He'd be able to get 20 to be anybody
to have to pay minus a hundred and a
hundred
okay.
He'd pay $100 if the Yankees one
and get $100 if the Phillies won.
Okay.
And so that way he get he breast cancel
his bed at the end and end up with $20
for sure. Okay. So just to say it again,
he's made money apparently because he
knows more than the Philly fan knows.
But actually in order to guarantee
that he doesn't run a risk,
he has to find another trader.
And,
and it's the presence of the other trader
who's willing to get really giving him
his profit opportunity,
not as superior knowledge and the
fact that it's two different traders.
And so why does that
give them an opportunity?
Because he can arrange a bet with a
Philly fan and a bet with the, uh,
bookie bookie, but
combined with a, you know,
borrowing the money so
that in the end he's, uh,
he's gonna just get zero payoffs putting
together the Philly fan bet and the
bookie bet and borrowing $20,
he gets $20 at the very
beginning and on net.
He has nothing at the end.
So whatever losses he got from the
Phillies he made up from the book,
he bet whatever losses
he had from the book,
he bet he made up for it
with the Philly fan bet.
So arbitrage relies on
replication somehow through some
other bet. He was able, he was
able to hedge his other bat,
is able to hedge his Phillies bat,
um,
by replicating the bet with somebody
else combined with borrowing to produce
exactly the same,
uh,
payoffs in the end or the negative
of the payoffs and the end.
And yet for a different price at the
beginning of the Philly fan didn't demand
any money up front to make this a
hundred minus hundred bet with him. And,
and with the a bookie, he's able
to get $20 up front and make this,
uh, you know, the opposite bet, the
minus hundred hundred bet. Okay.
So by getting more money up front and
doing the opposite bet with the bookie,
he can end up completely cancelling
the Philly bet. Can we fan bet?
And that's how he makes us profit.
Okay. So, um, that was the first idea.
And so what have I clarified?
What I've clarified is that it
wasn't a superior knowledge.
It was the presence of two
different traders that enabled
him to make his profit.
And I've clarified the method
that he made the profit,
the profit wasn't just kind
of mixing in another bet.
It was really cleverly arranging
to undo totally the original bed.
Okay. So he got actually zero in the end.
It ended up with $20 at the beginning.
So let's just see now what you
would do in a dynamic situation.
Yes,
yes.
Why would he do what at all?
It seems like no matter what,
whether they win or lose together,
he didn't have $20 to begin with.
He had no dollars.
So he went and found the Philly fan and
he made a bet against the Philly fan
with no money.
Right.
The Philly fan was ma was willing
to bet him $100 on the Phillies,
so he gets a hundred if the Yankees
winning pays the fan a hundred if the
Phillies win,
it didn't cost him any money to do that.
Then he goes out and makes another
bet with the bookie. Again,
it doesn't cost him any money.
He gives up $80 if the Yankees win,
but he gets 120 if the fillings win.
So he spent no money at all.
And his total profit is $20 for sure.
So what could he do?
Since he knows he's going to
make $20 for sure in the future,
he could just borrowed at the beginning.
If the interest rate zero
have $20 at the beginning,
end up with zero no matter what the
uncertainty is and put the $20 in his
pocket. So that that's, so that's
another way of saying the same thing,
which is that he could, by combining the
bets put as pocket in at the beginning.
And no matter what happens in the future,
he doesn't have to give anybody any
more money. So that's what he's done.
That's what an arbitrage is. You put
money in your pocket and in the future,
in the present, and in the future,
you never have to face a problem.
You've always got money
that's going out in one hand,
you're getting from the other hand.
Okay?
Now in a dynamic situation, you
can do the same thing. Okay?
So I'm just reinterpreting what
we did before a little bit.
So in the dynamic situation,
what are you doing?
You've got the Philly fan now is
betting on the whole world series,
even though you know
the odds are 60 40 okay,
so now it's an even worse
back by the Philly Fan. If
you're right about the odds,
because the chances are even higher that
the Yankees are going to win the series
than one game. The odds we know
are 71% so by backward induction,
we did this calculation to say you're
expected payoff is $42 so let's suppose
now, but, but now the key
is that you're making money,
not just because you know
better what the odds are.
You're making money because there's
another book he's standing there always
ready to trade with you
at 60 40 odds on any game.
So the presence of the second book,
even if you knew nothing,
would enable you to make money in
this case, lock in a profit for sure.
A $42 now how do you know that
you can lock in a profit for sure.
$42 well,
it's now done by dynamic hedging.
You have to
lay off part of your bat
a little part each day,
each game and the amount that you lay
off is going to depend on what happens.
So that's why it's dynamic.
It's a complicated calculation,
so it seems almost hopeless to
figure out what to do. You know,
like I'm betting on the whole series, you
know, many different things can happen.
You know, the Phillies could
win the first game, the Yankees,
good win the first game.
Lots of things could happen by the end.
I want to make sure I've locked in my
profit for sure. How can I do that?
Well, the key is to think
about marking to market.
Just as we said.
Okay.
If you're
okay
assessing your position correctly,
even though the world series
take seven games after,
if you were reporting to your investors,
you're the,
you are a hedge fund, you're reporting
to your investors. How you're doing.
You should be telling them
after the first game, you know,
at the beginning you're telling them,
look,
I'm going to make $42 I expect to make
$42 after the Yankees win the first game.
Looks like you're going to make 60
you know, now things are better.
You expect to make $64 on average.
But if the Yankees lost the first game,
you can only expect to make $9 on average.
So after the first game,
you go from thinking you're going to
make 42 to meaning even more optimistic.
Now you're gonna make 64 or
are you going to make nine?
So 60% times 64 plus 40% of mine is 42.
So if you were mark telling your investors
properly how you stood after the very
first game,
you might have to tell them you've lost
33 of the $42 that you told them before
you are going to make. So you'd
already be taking, you know,
we'll be running a risk.
You really only care maybe about
getting money for sure by the end.
But if you're doing proper accounting,
you should be worried all the way along,
whether you're making or losing money.
And that's the key to how to uh,
have no risk by the end. You just run
no risk at all. The in between stages.
So all you have to do is make a bet with
a bookie who's standing by to make $33
in case the Phillies win the first game
and making a one game get in exchange
for losing $22 if the Yankees win,
this is still three to two odds.
So the book is willing to do it.
So the night before the first game you,
you've bet with the Philly fan on
the entire series, which is you know,
giving you a huge advantage but you're
willing to bet with the other bookie.
The other book, he, we're assuming
it's only standing by game by game.
You're betting 33 to 22 on the Phillies.
You're betting on the
team you expect to lose.
You're betting on that team with the
other bookie but in a smaller quantity.
So this is going to mean vet your profit
at the end of the first day after,
after the first game, no matter
what happens is still going to be 42
so you can guarantee you can
lock in 42 after every game.
And so as I said last time,
the crucial thing is so then the,
so then one thing I didn't
say, so one thing to, uh,
which I forgot to observe last time,
which I think is interesting is
so is that what you should do?
Should you do that after every
game? Always Bet 33 to 22, uh,
you know, against the Yankees with
the other bookie of the answer is no.
Okay. What should you do if
the Yankees win the first game?
By winning the first game,
your expectation goes up to 64.
Now it could be either 82 or 30,
but after,
so on the night after the first game,
you're much better off than
you were before. Of course,
you laid off part of the bet with
the bookies you've had to pay off 22.
So you're still only 42 ahead.
But the Yankees have
now won the first game.
So it's now the night after the
first game, before the second game,
you're subject to more risk.
What should you do now?
You should go back to the book and
make another bad on the second game.
But should the other bet be 22 to 33
absolutely not because 64 up here goes to
whatever that number is,
which I forgot already.
82 and a half to 36 and a half.
Okay,
so what should you do?
What did you do now?
So I've done some rounding here,
which is going to screw everything up
a little bit, but while I'm not now,
what should you do here after the
first game? You're here. Here you are.
After the first game
you've made your bed, um,
with the book the first game,
you bet 33 against 22.
Now what should you do the second game?
What should your bet be with that bookie,
he's still willing to give you three to
two odds on the Yankees either direction.
What should you do?
Okay,
you're not going to bet 33 22 again,
you're going to make a different
pet and what should it be? Yes,
exactly.
So you should do,
you should give up 18 if the
Yankees win and get 27 rounding up.
She conveniently rounded a little bit
because I had rounded a little bit.
So you should do 18 and 27.
Now notice that's still three to two odds.
So the book,
he's still willing to do that for you
and you're locking in the 64 because it's
going to be 64 again. And you
know, adding this a 64 again,
but of course you'd already, right, so
you've locked in whatever this number is.
So the first step, you made a bet to
lock this number in. In the second step,
you made a bet to walk this number and
you're always walking in where you were
before.
So that bed is changing each time,
but you're always walking in what you
were before because after the Yankees have
won the game, now you
know, the next game is, uh,
not quite as important that you know,
the time is running out on the
Phillies so that it's not as, uh,
you know, revealing the next game
about what's going to happen. So, um,
you make a smaller bet up
here than you did before.
Okay, so that, so why is
that locking everything in?
Because this average is now 64
what was here. But don't forget,
you'd already made the initial bet to
lose 22 so you've locked in 44 now here
and also 44 here cause you still
over 22 from the first bet. Okay?
So you just keep proceeding down the tree,
locking in where you were before.
And so by induction you've locked
in 42 so that's what you're doing.
And the bat is changing every time.
So what do you think the bed is here,
by the way?
The bed here or you could go
from nine you can go from nine to
36 or minus 32 so what should you do here?
What's your,
do you do here?
What's the bet that you're going to make
with the bookie after the Phillies win
the first game?
So it's going to be minus
27 and plus 41 okay.
And that's, you know, all three to
two odds with some rounding. Right?
13 and a half times three is 40 and
a half. So it's still fair odds.
Okay.
So the book, he's willing to do that.
You've locked in nine. So bite induction,
you've always locked in where you were
before and therefore you've locked in 42
all the way along. You know, it
sounds like we're lacking in nine,
but we're not locking a nine.
Because remember the first day you won
$33 from the bookie when the Phillies won
the first game. So you've locked in the
nine, but don't forget the 33 from before.
So it's really, you've locked in 42.
So 42 is locked in the whole way. Okay?
So that's dynamic hedging.
You, you, you, uh,
have a complicated bat along. That
depends on a lot of things along the way,
but you bet each time,
along the way,
maybe changing her bad each time
depending on what's happened so far.
And that way you can lock
in whatever profit you had.
So that's the thing that sports
bookies have known for a long time.
You know, the expression hedging
your bets comes from that.
And so that same logic can
be applied to the market.
Okay. But remember the
crucial, okay, so the,
the step that I didn't emphasize
very much is that although you're,
you're, you know, you seem to be
locking in where you were before,
there was a slightly more abstract way
of saying that that at the end you're
going to get $42 a for sure.
So of course you could borrow all the
way back from the beginning and get $42
immediately and then never
owe anything in the future.
Cause whatever bet you were winning
or losing with the Philly fan you were
making up for with your myriad
bets with the bookie. Okay.
So it's a,
it's a replication argument that by
betting sequentially with a bookie,
different amounts,
you're undoing the single long
bet you had with the Philly fan.
Okay?
Okay.
So now let's move from sports
as we did last time too.
Um,
the market.
So here we had the prepayment
spreadsheet and so we had,
remember this was a,
this was a bond,
a mortgage, the 30 year
mortgage, 8% mortgage,
and the interest rates started off
at 6% and had a 20% volatility.
And now your thinking of a,
so the interest rates could follow
this process there you see it,
they started 6% but they can go up or
down by 20% basically every period.
So you assume that everybody knows this
and knows that the probabilities are 50
50.
That's like saying you know,
in advance there's a bookie out there
that is the market that's willing to give
you no matter what day it is,
50 50 odds of the interest rate
going up or down from then on.
That's just like the book he's
standing by. Now this time though,
you're going to have to,
okay. So that's how that,
so you now are going to take advantage
of the fact that you can anticipate that
the market will stand there
ready, uh, to, to bet with you.
Now if the whole market freezes or
something, you can be totally screwed.
You're doing your complicated dynamic,
you know, betting with the market.
One day you wake up and you can't bend
anymore because nobody's willing to train
something horrible's happened, you know,
nine 11 happened or something like that.
You can be caught in a really
bad situation and ended
up running a lot of risk.
Okay,
so you're relying on the market.
So it's not surprising that
when the market freezes up,
lots of people suddenly are exposed
to more risks than they were before.
All right? Now let's, uh,
let's suppose that so now in the market
you're not going to be able to find
these pure arbitrage is in the sports
example, it was a pure arbitrage.
There was a Philly fan who is betting
and even odds and a bookie who is betting
at three to two odds. Now, you
shouldn't expect that to happen. I mean,
by what miracle did this fan come to
you instead of to the other bookie?
You know, why do you deserve to meet
this fan and take advantage of him?
What have you got that
no other book he has?
It's a miracle he came to you and not to
one of the other hundred bookies. Well,
it's probably because you actually know
something that the other bookies don't,
that you can take advantage of.
So in the background here,
there's another thing that you knew,
you knew the fan was going
to pay off if he lost,
maybe the other bookies weren't willing
to bet with him because they didn't
think he was going to pay off if he lost.
Okay?
So that's the extra thing that you knew,
you knew he was going to pay off.
Now it makes sense that he came to you
and not to the other book is because you
actually knew something that they don't.
Okay?
And so that's how it
really works in the market.
You're relying on some piece
of information you have
that they don't. Of course,
you could be wrong about that information.
Then you get into a lot of troubles.
So here in this mortgage,
what's the thing you're relying on?
I'm assuming that there's a bookie that
the rest of the market is standing by.
Ready? As I said to trade, make
interest rate bets with you. Okay?
With everybody at even odds.
You know, whether the market,
whether the interest
rate's gonna go up or down.
So no matter where you find
yourself in the future, like here,
someone's be willing to vet in 50
50 odds that will go up or down.
Now this is a year long bet.
So you're gonna have to take
into account the interest rate.
It's not just going to be 50 50 you know
you have to discount all the cash flows
by the interest rate,
but it's basically a 50 50 bet discounted
by the interest rate. So now what?
What's new here? Well, you don't
know what the cash flows are. Okay?
So here's the extra piece of information
you're adding. You know that the, the,
the mortgage homeowner is rational
and it's going to prepay rationally.
So you know what these cash flows are.
You know,
some of the time the mortgage
homeowner's going to pay the $8 CEOs,
some of the time he's just
going to pay $8. In fact,
here is what you know is going to
happen down here where the ones are,
he's going to pay as coupon of eight
pay off the remaining principle.
And that's the end of it. So,
in fact, the very first day he,
if interest rates went down,
the rational thing to do is to
pay off the entire mortgage. Okay.
So you know that's going to happen. Now.
That's the extra information you have.
You know what the cash flows are.
If other people knew those cash flows,
they would figure out the
price of the mortgage too.
It's just they don't know those,
you know,
the cash flows and you can now figure out
that the price better be 98 because if
it's why,
if there's someone else willing to trade
with you to buy that mortgage for more
than 98. Okay. Like why might that happen?
Because someone else might have the
erroneous opinion that the homeowner will
never call.
The mortgage will never prepay cause he's
just going to be asleep all the time.
So let's say, um, let's say
it's a, the homeowners, a she,
let's say the homeowners are all,
she's this,
this other trader thinks they're
all asleep and we'll never prepay.
You know that these homeowners are all
incredibly alert and on top of things.
And so they're going to prepay and the
value's only 98 so because of that extra
information, you know the actual
cashflows, sorry, we're here.
You know the cash flows,
you know how to value the bond
and you know it's worth 98 okay?
But you can so,
and let's say the other guy's willing
to pay you 124 so you can sell it short
for a,
you can sell it to the Guy Short for 120
that means you owe whatever cash flows
the mortgage pays. Okay? And you know
what it's going to pay down there.
So how can you lock in your profit will
because with $98 at the very beginning,
you can replicate those cash flows.
You can go out into the market
and buy those cashflows.
The very cashflows you know the mortgage
is going to make. How can you do that?
Well, because of the first step.
Remember what this says, the first step,
the price is 98 the interest
rate could go up or down.
If the interest rate goes up,
the payment is eight that's
the coupon plus 92 something.
Now you need 2.6 and if it goes down,
the payment is eight okay,
so what is this?
The payment is actually eight that's
the cash flow that has to be made.
The mortgage wasn't called here at the
beginning, so no matter what she does,
the homeowner,
she's got to pay the eight so you know
you're going to owe the guy ate the first
period. Now down here, she's
actually going to prepay,
so she's actually going to pay
the guy the whole 99.1 up here.
She's not going to prepay.
She's going to hang on to the mortgage.
So what is this 92.6 this
is the present value,
assuming those cashflows
of her future payments.
So if you get $98 you know
that one half times this,
this by the way is 102.6 so one half times
this divided by 1.06 plus this thing,
remember is one oh seven one one
divided by 1.06 times a half.
That's how we got the number
98 98.8 whatever it was.
That's how you calculated 98.8 by backward
induction and took this value divak
times a half discounted plus this value
times a half discounted that say you got
98.8 so therefore if people are
willing to trade at these prices,
in other words,
what's the price here?
It's a half times one over 1.06 and this
is a half times one of 1.06 you can buy
a dollar here at a cost of one half
times 1.06 you can buy a dollar here at a
cost of a half divided by 1.06
paying this amount at the beginning.
We'll buy you a dollar here paying
this amount at the beginning.
We'll buy you a dollar here.
So by paying this amount,
you can get this pay off a 102.6 a 100.6
or 800.6 you can get this hundred 0.6
and you can get 107 point
11 because precisely this
is the cost that you have to
pay for each dollar up here.
And this is the cost
that you have to pay here for each
dollar down here. Why is that?
Because we said the market is standing
by recognizing that these are 50 50 odds
and then it has to discount.
So that means the whole market is
willing to train you. Uh, you know,
we'll be willing to promise you a dollar
here in exchange for this amount of
dollars here.
It'll be willing to promise you a dollar
here and in exchange for this amount of
dollars here.
So with this amount of dollars,
you can buy $8 and have 92.6 leftover and,
and you can also buy $8
here with 99.11 leftover.
So all of this together is enough to
make the prepayment cause you know she's
going to prepay here.
That's what we found out.
She's going to prepay
it the first step down.
What would the headlines say?
Okay.
She's pretty pain.
Just as we said at the very first step,
she's prepaying the first interest
rate down. She's going to prepay.
So we know you're going to have
to come up with all this money.
But you've bought it over here, it costs
you this amount and you bought all that.
If things went up, you'd have to pay
eight okay. Which you've also bought,
but you've got 92.6 leftover and that's
going to be enough to buy everything
that comes after that because the next
day you're going to have to buy more
stuff.
And so you just keep buying going forward.
So with $98.80 you can buy all the future
cash flows and you sold the thing so
you can make all your payments that
you're obliged to selling it short.
And he received 120 to begin with.
So you locked in $21.20 okay.
So that's the gist of the whole
thing. So okay, I said it last time.
Not very well. I said it a little bit
better this time. Still not brilliantly.
But do you get now get it.
Someone asked me a question perhaps.
Is it
okay? So two, I'll say
the, the punchline again,
the punch line is that if
you can find a favorable,
so here,
what was different about the world series
and the mortgage example in the world
series,
you took advantage of the fact that there
was a bookie and a Philly fan willing
to bet at different
odds on the same thing.
And so even though the Philly fan
had a very complicated, you know,
seven day bed and the Yankee,
the bookies,
the other bookies were rolling,
willing to make day by day bats,
you could take advantage of that
disparity to lock in a profit for sure.
And that's what you should
try to do in the market.
Your probably relying on something else.
You're relying on the fact that you know
more about the cash flows then the rest
of the traders do.
The rest of the market does.
Maybe cause you understand
prepayments better than they do. Okay.
And so that's why I said it was so
important to, you know, model prepayments.
So let's say you understand prepayments
better than they do. So you know what?
The cash flows are going to be
much better than the market does.
You can take advantage of
that in front of, okay,
so you're taking advantage of you.
You need now this advantage,
just like in the world series,
you might have needed the advantage of
knowing the Philly fan would actually pay
off if he lost.
So there's that advantage that you have
and now you have to rely on the fact
that the market or the bookie
from then on day by day,
year by year is willing
to make bets at these, uh,
odds that you can anticipate.
And so using that you can trade over and
over again with the rest of the market
and dynamically replicate what,
uh,
the payments you have to make
by selling the bond short.
So therefore you've locked in your
profit because you can anticipate,
assuming the market stays, they're
willing to trade it, even odds,
you'll always be able to produce the cash
flows with the $98 you started with to
exactly meet all your payment obligations
you've incurred by selling the
mortgage short. And since you
sold it at the beginning for 120,
you've made $21 at the beginning
and you'll never need those dollars.
You just put them in your
pocket. Okay? So that's the, uh,
okay.
So that's how the dynamically hedge a
winning position to eliminate the chance
of loss. Of course, you
still bear a chance of loss.
If you are wrong about the prepayments,
you're going to lose money.
And if the rest of the market suddenly
stops being there to make these year by
your bets on which way
interest rates are going to go,
you'll also be subject to a lot of risk.
So you're relying on those two things.
The whole market not collapsing and
you're being right about prepayments.
But conditional on those two facts,
you've locked in your profits,
you got rid of a bunch of risk,
the blind luck of a hundred minus a
hundred from the roll of the dice of the
Phillies.
You've got rid of that lock,
but you still had to count on the bookie
being there day after day after day and
on the fact.
Yeah.
And in the mortgage case and the
fact that you knew how to predict the
prepayments.
Yes.
Okay. I never made 42 on the
first bet here at the beginning.
Nothing's happened yet. The series hasn't
been played yet. So I say to myself,
I've made this hundred dollar bet with
the Philly fan for the whole series and
who's going to win the series?
That's going to happen seven days later.
So right now I can anticipate on average,
I'll make $42 some of the time I'll
lose a hundred some of the time I win a
hundred but an average,
I'll come up $42 a head.
But so I've done a smart thing
betting with the naive Philly fan,
but I'm still potentially screwed.
I could still lose $100 I'll still have
to face my investors and tell them I've
lost all your money. They'll, you
know, they're going to close me down.
And that's the,
so I don't want to run that risk.
They don't want me to run that risk
and I don't want to run the risk.
I still want to take
advantage of the Philly fan.
So what I do is every game I make
another bet against my inclination.
I bet not on the Phillies. I
bet. I mean not on the Yankees.
So I think they're gonna win.
I'm betting on the Phillies cause I'm
undoing part of the gamble that I did with
this guy. I'm hedging that gamble.
But by doing that in a clever way,
changing how much money, I bet each
game. So the night before the first game,
I bet $33 to $22 on the Phillies winning
after the ink is when the first game,
I bet $27 to $18 again on
the Phillies winning. Okay?
So I decrease my bet going up.
I increase it going down.
So by doing these clever
game by game bets,
I lock in $42 for sure.
Yes.
Okay. So you have locked it
in. So how could that be?
So that's a good question. But you've
overlooked something. So her question is,
you know,
the game is going to end after seven days.
What if I ended with a
minus a hundred you know,
I ended the Philly's won all four games.
It doesn't look like I've lost.
So why didn't I lose?
Okay,
I bet a hundred with the original
Philly fan,
I bet $100 on the Yankees of the Phillies.
We in all Ford first four games,
I've got to give the guy $100 okay?
Of course I made these side bets
with all these books on the way.
So what were the side bets?
Don't meet those that are secure that
I love the rent was coming out of it.
There's going to be an end
situations. You're up $42 but we're
trying to understand why that is.
That's your question, right? So I'm,
you're going to be able to
answer the question. Uh,
although you don't think so yet,
but so what happened the first time?
The first time the Phillies won.
Okay.
That bet with the original
Philly fan is looking worse.
Now it looks like I had 44
to $42 I expected to win. No,
I only expect to win $9 because you
know the series is turning against me.
But the book,
He paid me $33 so I'm
$33 already in my pocket.
This is nine.
Now let's say I got to the end to the
last game where this was a zero okay,
let's say this is the last
game where I've lost, okay,
well this is minus 32 let's say it was
minus. Let's say this is the last game.
I lose $32 here.
Let's say the bat,
it was only a two game series and I lose
30 I give up $32 in case the Phillies
win the first two games,
right?
So you're saying I'm down
$32 that's the last node.
How can I possibly be up 42 well,
so what's the answer?
What?
Right? Because I bet on the
first game and the book,
the first book he gave me $33 then the
second game I'm going to bet with the
bookie and I'm going to
be minus 27 and 41 okay,
so although I now all the Philly Fan,
$33 here,
I made $41 with the second bookie
and $33 with the first bookie,
that's $74 and I paid 32
to the original Philly fan.
So I'm still up $42 okay. Now,
just so it sounds like you
have to do a lot of arithmetic.
You don't have to do any arithmetic.
I knew I was going to end up $42 up.
How is that? Because every bed, I
said, let's look at the number here.
Wherever we are in the tree,
like here at this node,
after all the stuff
that's happened before,
the bet I'm going to make with the bookie,
that one game is going to be enough to
turn this random thing and to 64 64 okay.
So I always take what happens further
down the tree and turn it in to what's
happened at the beginning of the tree.
But then I work at all the way back
and it's 42 okay. So that means,
see this thing was 64 nine but I made a
bad 22 to 33 but the bookie to turn it
into 42 42 this thing was 64 I made
a bet to turn this into 64 64 okay.
But with the 22 here, that's also 42
so no matter how far I go on the tree,
I'm still exactly 42 ahead.
Okay. Any other questions?
Yes.
Okay.
Sorry. What am I doing? We're, we're
okay. So her question is,
in this case, the mortgage.
So now we're moving from the world
series to more real life. In this case,
I know the cashflows from this mortgage
or worth 98.8 but somebody else not
understanding the homeowner
and how rational she is,
someone else is willing to
pay me 120 for that mortgage.
So I sell the mortgage for 120 and
I take $21 and put it in my pocket.
Okay, now I've got $98.80
left. So that's money.
Now I have to do something
active with what do I have to do?
I owe this guy a lot of payments.
Every time she,
lets say it's you makes your payment,
her payment,
you know in the market I've sold
the thing short. That means I owe,
I've promised to deliver
whatever that mortgage delivers.
That's what it means to sell it short. So
I've got to deliver the eight here. Say,
okay so how am I, I've got to live with
eight here and here. She's prepaying,
I have to deliver the whole hundred seven
all right,
so with $98.80 I can afford to buy a
$100.60 in this state and a 107.11 in this
state. How do I know that? Because
that's where the 98.8 came from.
It said this total amount
of 100.6 times the price,
which is the odds of it happening,
discounted.
That's the price plus the
hundred 7.11 times it's priced.
The odds that happens.
Discounted.
Okay is exactly 98.8 that's where I got
98.8 so therefore with $98.80 remember
the book,
he's willing to go either way with $98.80
I can buy all these cash flows and all
these cash flows.
So what do I do with the hundred
0.6 so with the 107.1 down here,
I pay the eight her coupon
and her 99.11 prepayment.
I pay it all to that guy sold the bond
short too. And I've kept my promise.
That's the end of the mortgage appear.
The mortgage only delivered eight.
So I only owe him eight.
Okay.
But I've got another 92.6 left.
Why is that exactly what I need?
Because from here on,
I have to use that money to buy the
future cashflows cause she's going to
continue to pay her eight
and maybe eventually we will
prepay. But by induction,
by repeating the step over and over again,
I can always make the payment and have
the present value leftover to afford to
buy the future payments plus
the present value leftover.
So by induction I'm
always making the coop.
Like in this first step I
make the coupon payment,
plus I've got enough money leftover
to match the present value.
So that means as I go
forward and Ford and Ford,
I keep making the payment and matching
the present value that's leftover.
By the time I get to the 30th year,
I've made the coupon payment,
the present value leftover zero cause
there isn't gonna be any payments after
that.
So I've made all the payments.
Yeah.
Yes I could.
Okay.
So I was hoping you wouldn't
ask me that because it's um,
so what happens in the next period?
So here we know that she didn't pay,
she didn't prepay.
This was 90 to the present value is 92.6
so we're here 92.6 now she didn't pray.
Let's look at what she's doing,
whether she's prepaying or not. Okay?
So this is why I did the second graph.
So if the interest rates go up
the first time and then back down,
she's still not going to prepay.
Okay?
So we can now go up and see,
oops,
let's see.
Okay, here we are. So we can go up
now and see what's happening here.
It's 92.65 go up to 83.95
or down to um,
97.2
I need 7.17. Okay, so what does that
mean? That means what the, okay,
so with $98.80 she bought a,
he I bought,
I'm the guy selling the thing short.
You're the smart, rational prepare.
So you paid $8 here.
That means because I've sold the
mortgage short and you've paid,
you've made that $8 payment.
I owe the guy the $8 payment
just as if he had the mortgage.
So I've got to come up with the $8
down here. Things had moved here,
you would have paid $8
plus the whole prepayments.
You would have paid $107 but with 98.8
I can buy eight plus 92.6 up here.
April's 99.11 down here.
So I bought all the cashflows
I need to down here.
I hand them over to the guy and they say,
you see,
I kept my promise to deliver whatever
that mortgage did and I knew that she was
going to prepay. I knew how smart
she was and so I've kept my promise.
You didn't think she'd prepay. I knew
what. I've kept my promise. Okay,
and then up here I've got the $8
so I can make the payment match it.
I've got 92.6 left now I don't give it
to the guy because the payment's only
been eight.
I take the 92.6 and with the 92.6 that
happens to equal this plus eight times a
half divided by 1.06 and then equals
also this plus eight times a half divided
by 1.06, uh, not by 1.6
by the interest rate here,
which happens to be, you have to figure
out what that interest rate was up there.
Um
mm.
So the interest rate went up to it started
at 6% and went up to old seven three
2%.
So this is 0.0732
how did this number 92.6 get calculated?
It was exactly.
Take the payment of Eight,
take the present value of what's left,
multiply by half and discounted at the
interest rate here plus a half times,
uh,
this payment of eight plus the
remaining plus the value of what's left
discounted by that.
It's interest rate.
So this is number 92.6 allows
me to buy this and to buy that.
So therefore if things went up again,
okay,
I could make her eight your $8 payment
that you make to the bank I have to make
to the other guy because I sold the Morgan
Short, I've got the money to pay him.
I've also got the money to pay
him if things had gone down again,
$8 and I've got more cash in my pocket,
this and this and the two
cases with this money,
I can continue to buy the future
payments that you're going to make.
So I always have enough money to make
whatever payments it is that you,
that I have to to keep my promise.
Yup. Correct. From your point of view,
go up because your theory
about prepayments isn't
going to be put to the test.
Um,
well don't forget I'm locking
in my $21 profit for sure.
So no matter what happens,
I'm going to just be able to make
all the payments no matter what.
But that assumes that you're hearing
about prepayments, correct? Yes.
So yes. Right. Not just
put it on one risk.
Right.
So it's sort of,
okay. So go ahead. So let me
repeat his question and feel free,
give me in slightly different words.
He's saying that I was able to take it.
This is what my hedge fund does.
Literally we think we know better what
the prepayments are going to be then the
rest of the market.
So we're willing to take on a commitment.
Someone will pay us $120 we think
we're only going to have to, you know,
$98 or enough to buy all the,
all the promises that we've made by
selling the thing short say now how do we,
we could be wrong.
We have been wrong last two years.
We made a lot of mistakes. So, um,
your saying the question is okay.
Uh,
the reason why the guy is willing to pay
so much is because down here he thinks
he's going to get a lot of
money. The interest rates
are going down. So you know,
discounting at a lower rate, the
mortgage is going to be worth a lot more.
We don't think it's going to be
worth more because we're expecting,
okay up here it's sort of obvious that
there aren't going to be any prepayments.
So if the world really goes
interest rates going up,
then our theory of prepayments
never gets put to the test.
And so we just make money in this
guy, you know? And so I mean,
so our theory never gets put to the test.
If interest rates go down,
then our theory has been really put to
the test and we have to see whether she's
really smart enough to prepay or not.
So you're right, that's absolutely true.
Yup.
But in any case,
we're going to assume our theory is
correct and hedge in such a way so that if
our theory is correct about prepayments,
we will exactly be in a position to
keep our promises without ever running a
risk of loss.
Yes.
Yup.
There are two situations where the
Phillies win four games or they win the
series.
Either way you $100 and
you win a single game vets.
But in one of those situations
and one single game,
that one in five games rather than
okay.
Because it couldn't have happened that
there were four straight wins and then a
lost the series would have
been over. Right. So therefore,
uh,
you're,
so his question is I've asserted
that no matter what the way,
what way things go, I'm going to
end up $42 a head no matter what.
And he's saying that's great,
but he's a little skeptical.
It could be true because I'm always
betting against this other bookie.
I'm always betting on the Phillies with
the other bookie. And so in one case,
uh, the Yankees win four in a row, I just,
I lose for bats with the other bookie.
In the other case with the bookie,
I'm betting on the Philly. So I've,
I've had to take for losing bets with
the other bookie in the case where the
Yankees win three lose one.
And then when in the end,
I've again lost four bets
with the other bookie.
But I've actually won a
bet with the other bookie.
So it seems like somehow
things are better for me.
And so it seems unbelievable that
I'm still at 42 in both cases.
That's your question. Right.
Okay. So the puzzle, the,
the reason is that,
um,
my bets are changing.
So after I don't make the same last bed.
Okay. So the first three bats, there's
a Yankee, Wayne Yankee. When Yankee,
when each of those nights, I'm making
the same bet in the same scenario,
but when the Phillies lose
and then win again, I changed.
I've changed my bet.
So I'm still going to end up with a,
I'm still going to end up. So
the, so the Yankees lost the, uh,
your scenario was the Yankees
lost the fourth game. Okay.
So that outcome is different from what
it would have been in the first scenario
because the Yankees
lost instead of winning.
So the bookie bat went the other
way now. Okay. So that was a,
but now the f the last bet I made is not
the same bet as I would have made the
night before.
It's a tour.
It's a different bet so that it just ends
up with the different direction in the
fourth bet.
Plus this different fifth bet.
It adds back up to what
would have happened had the
Yankees won the fourth time.
I don't know if that helps. But
that's what happens. And, and the,
and the proof that it happens is just by
induction. So really your, your, you know,
I gave a proof and your saying the
proof is just, it's amazingly good.
Remember the proof is very simple.
You always make a bet. So let,
no matter what happens,
you're expectation is back to where it
was the night before. And if you do that,
you have to end up,
that's the proof that you've always
locked in 42 from the beginning. And so,
you know,
you can ask a thousand questions like
that and it's always going to be a
complicated answer. But there has
to be an answer cause we proved it.
There was one.
Okay.
Okay. Any other questions about this? Yes,
Morgan.
So with the mortgage example, your
hedging against the interest rate going,
uh, no. When the interest rate goes up,
you actually pay less, right?
That's that. You've made a promise.
Remember the price as the interest rate
goes up. Where's the mortgage? Sorry?
The value of the non call,
the value of the call.
So is the interest rate goes up,
you owe less money,
right? Cause you're promising to deliver
this stuff. So we interest rates up.
The mortgage you've sold short
is less and less valuable.
So that's the good scenario for you.
But if the interest rate goes down,
that's the scenario where you could
get into trouble. So you're hedging,
you're trying to protect against
the interest rate going down.
In order to do that, you
have to give money up in case
the interest rate goes up.
Okay. So now I want to, I want to,
uh, any other questions about this?
It's quite an ingenious thing.
I think this is the high, so we're
going to have one more step of this,
but this is the high watermark of
the standard. Uh, you know, the,
the finance guys who made finance
such an important subject and,
um, you know, the rational
expectations, school of finance,
this is kind of the most
clever thing that they did.
So this was this kind of
reasoning, you know, uh, bookies,
maybe new ad for a long time,
but black shoals in 1973 started this
kind of thinking and then lots of hedge
funds started imitating it,
including my own. So, so I,
I certainly didn't invent this
idea of dynamic hedging. Now
let's take a step back.
The crucial idea is marking to market.
The crucial idea is that you want to
hedge through millions of scenarios and
really the outcome,
you won't know until the end.
What you should do is hedge at each,
at each step of the way your
mark to market value. Okay?
So you only have to do things
a step at a time. So, you know,
there's an exponentially
growing number of paths,
but there are only two possibilities
from today til tomorrow.
So it's very simple to hedge.
Two things seems incredibly complicated
to as hedge to to the hundred things you
know, to the 10th is a very big
number. Two was a very small number.
You can hedge to things that may be
very complicated to hedge two to the 10
things, but you only have to hedge
to things on every day. Okay?
So once you've realized that hedging
is actually quite a simple operation,
you don't have to do it by trading in
the interest rate derivatives market.
You could trade in a simpler market.
Suppose for example,
that you knew that uh,
there were bonds being traded,
you know,
let's say 30 year bonds. So let's just
take a look at a 30 year bond here.
Um,
cold barn.
So this is exactly the same thing.
This is the 30 year bond under the
same circumstances. It's a 9% bond,
9% bond, okay? Coupon bond,
and it starting with the
same 6% interest rates.
Exactly the same process as before.
Okay?
Okay. So the interest rates, those are
the same. Interest rates is before. Okay?
So here's the bond.
Now the bond,
okay,
the bond,
it starts at $140.
You can go to $121 at $159.
Hey,
remember this thing that you're trying
to hedge goes from 98.8 to a hundred 0.6
or 207.11 okay?
So what you need to do now is you're,
you've promised to make
deliveries in the future,
you know, very complicated, but you know,
you can summarize that whole future.
As long as you've got a hundred $0.60
in the upstate and $107.11 in the
downstate,
after the very first step,
you will have hedged your
mortgage obligation. But you know,
you could just buy the right percentage
of bonds and be able to accomplish the
same thing. So why is that? Well,
there's a gap here in here. You know,
you owe less money here
than you do down there.
So the bond is worth less
appear than down here. In fact,
this bond is worth $38
more here than here.
So the gap and the bond
is 38. The gap in the, uh,
in here is something like a
6.5.
Okay?
Okay,
so this is like one sixth.
So as long as you held
one sixth of the bond.
Okay.
One sixth of the bond.
Yeah.
And something that paid
the right constant amount.
In each case you would get the
same payments here in here.
So what is the right constant? Mt.
One sixth of the bond. By the way,
it would cost you 20 a
to 24 23 about $23 okay.
One Sixth of the bonds.
So if you took the other $98.80 and
put it to the one year treasury,
I claim it's obvious. So
take one, sixth of the,
so one sixth of 30 year,
9% bond. Okay, that's one
sixth of this thing. Okay.
Plus. Okay. Which costs
you cost you what it costs?
$23 price of that is $23 now combine
that with a $75.80 of one year treasury.
6% one year or 6% treasury.
Yeah.
Okay.
So hold those two things I claimed that'll
pay you a hundred 0.6 year and 107.11
here. How do I know that without having
to even calculate anything out? Well,
the Treasury is going to pay
the same amount here in here.
It's going to be a constant.
This thing,
since it's gap is $38 and
I only hold a sixth of it.
It's going to pay me exactly six and a
half more down here than a pace here.
Cause the gap instead of
38 will be a sixth of that,
which will be six and a half.
So the gap will exactly match that.
So added that to the treasuries,
constant payments.
I'm going to get something over here and
six and a half dollars more than that
down here, but since I've
paid the same amount, 98.8,
it's going to have to be that
that constant was exactly
right to make this be a
hundred 0.6 and 107.11 because both the
one year treasury and the 30 year bond
were calculated by discounting whatever
their payments were here in here by the
same prices, this and this.
Okay. So there's a second way.
Instead of trading in the, in the, in
the treasure, in the derivatives market,
I could just hold the,
uh,
a combination of two bonds though
one year treasury and the, um,
30 year, 9% bond, and I'd
still be perfectly hedged.
But then when I got to hear,
I'd want to change my mix.
I'd want to hold a different one
year bond, different interest rates.
So a different,
I have to buy a new one.
Your bond in a different amount
of the 30 year, a callable bond,
9% bond. But I could always
reproduce these same two payments.
So I don't have to hedge by holding
derivatives, interest rate to Rodeos.
I can hedge my holding standard bonds.
Okay.
And I can tell at a glance how much of
the longer term bond to hold because I
just have to match this gap and the prices
since the one year is always going to
pay the same thing up and down.
Okay.
Did that go too fast?
Yeah. Like this, this, but, but how
you, you figure out how to put one,
you're bothered by it.
Okay.
So I want to find,
I want to hold one sixth
of the 30 year bond,
which costs me 140 so one sixth of
that is going to cost me $23 okay?
So I know,
alright,
now I want to also hold a one
year treasury so that the payment,
one sixth of one 21 at the top plus
whatever the one year treasury pays me is
equal to 100.6 and such.
That one sixth time's this
value at the bottom. Oh, sorry,
it's one sixth.
This coupon is paying,
actually it wasn't 121.6 it's not 9% bond.
I forgot it's coupon. Very bad of me.
It won't change the numbers, but uh,
so it's, it's paying.
I didn't write it down.
So this thing is not paying 121
it's also paying the coupon.
This is the present value of what's left.
So I was paying nine plus that.
So it's 130 and here it's
168 the gap is still 38 okay.
So I want one sixth of a hundred
a 130 so one sixth of 130 costs.
Um,
it's still the same number is 22
did bad arithmetic to begin with.
So it's still 22 no, sorry, one
sixth. It's one sixth of this thing,
which is 140 so it's 23 right?
Sorry, I didn't change. Okay,
so the payment here is 130 and
the payment, here's 168 so I want,
so one sixth of 130 that's the UPPP
payment and this is one sixth of 168 okay.
Now I want that plus whatever the one
year treasury gives me to equal a hundred
0.6 up here and 107.11 down here.
That way I would have replicated things
and hedged myself perfectly. Right.
But I don't have to figure out
what that one year treasury is.
I think it's obvious.
All I have to do is say subtract 23 from
98.8 so I just have to buy $75.80 worth
of the one year treasury. And that'll
give me exactly the right payoff.
Why is that?
Because this number 140.93
okay.
Divided by six is exactly this evaluated
this price one half over 1.06 times
this. This is the price one
half times one over 1.06
right.
So that bond,
which costs 140.53 how
did I get 140.53 there?
I took the of a dollar and the upstate,
which is it's 50% likely discounted
multiplying by its payoff.
One 30 plus a half discounted multiplied
by the payoff of one 68 this is one 68
cause it's a 9% bond.
So it's one six times one six
so if I get a sixth of the bond,
it will cost me one 40.43
divided by six which is 23 okay.
So what about the one year treasury
that's going to give me some payment,
you know,
an additional payment here in here,
namely 1.06 times whatever I put in.
Okay,
so but you see the,
so that payment,
okay,
so you noticed that the
gap between here and here,
since I've multiplied by one six is
exactly the six and a half dollar gap.
So if I spend, the total I have
to spend is 98.8 over here.
Okay?
So if I spend $23 on the treasury
and the remaining amount,
$23 on a 30 year, 9% bond,
the remaining amount of money,
which is 75.8 on the treasury,
I will spend this $98.80 but then
I have to get the same payoffs.
Why is that? Because they're all
being priced at the same prices.
So it's just the distributor
of law of Arithmetic.
If these payoffs times the sixth okay.
Plus the treasury payoffs equal a hundred
0.6 and 107.11 then it must be that
the,
some of the money I spent on the,
on the 30 year 9% bond plus the son of
the money I spent on the treasury has to
equal mind the 8.8 therefore I know that
the amount of money I spent on 98 on
the amount of money,
the 98.8 I spend on the one year Treasury
was 98.8 minus the 23 I spent on the
um,
the night on the 30 year bond.
Okay.
Okay. So that's how you can,
uh, okay, so to say it again,
just in a big picture,
look there are two things that can happen.
If you hold to bonds a one year
treasury in a 30 year thing,
you're obviously going to be able to match
these two things by holding the right
proportion on them.
Okay.
That is just obvious and then less obvious
is how quickly I'm figuring out how
much of those two bonds to hold.
And the way I'm figuring it out so quickly
is because the one year treasury is
paying the same thing up and down.
So I have to get all the
variation out of the 30 year bond.
So I have to hold the right,
right proportion of the 30 year
bond to get the same variation.
Okay.
So in the very big picture,
if you're trying to hedge some instrument
with another instrument you want to,
uh, and something, you
know, a portfolio stuff,
much of which is is certain and
only one thing that's risky,
the amount of the risky thing you have
to hold has to produce as much variation
as the thing you're trying to hedge.
So the key is being able to tell at a
glance how much variation each thing has.
Then he can tell them what
proportion of the whole bum. Okay.
And so the very last thing I want
to tell you today, which is good,
unfortunately it take me a few minutes,
is how traders look at variation
and can guess it incredibly quickly.
So a trader could look at this and yes,
without doing almost any calculations
what the rate hedges. So just like we did,
did the doubling rule.
I want to do the variation rule of thumb.
Okay.
And so this is uh,
okay.
And this is called,
this is called duration and
convexity or average life.
So I asked myself,
suppose I have this 30 year bond,
30 year non callable bond.
That's this one. Okay.
9% bond.
How could,
I guess kind of what the variation in
price would be without having to do,
you know, I've had to do this
very complicated backward
induction calculation.
Now remember once the interest rates
go up here, it's a random walk.
So on average they're
pretty much not pretty much,
they're exactly what they were here,
you know, they're, they start here,
they go up and down.
But on average they're still here and
over here they've gone down. Okay.
So the average is lower going forward.
In fact, it's exactly equal to that.
So if you're a trader and
there was no uncertainty,
you would know that the present value
with no uncertainty is going to be the
coupon divided by one plus the interest
rate plus the coupon over one plus the
interest rate squared.
Plus in the last year the coupon over one
plus the interest rate to the t plus a
hundred times one plus the interest rate
the tea. That's the value of the bond.
Okay.
Now you're sort of want to know how much
is that price going to change when the
interest rate changes? Well, at a glance,
I mean you just take the derivative.
What is DPV Dr.
Okay.
It's going to be um,
minus C over one plus r squared
minus two c over one plus r cubed
minus,
um,
t time see over one
plus r to the t plus one
minus t times a hundred divided by
one plus r to the t plus one as the
derivative.
Okay,
so all I would say I'm making things even
more complicated you would think. But
yeah,
this turns out to be not so complicated.
Okay.
Because this is a number.
So let's put the minus on the outside.
It's all get rid of this.
This is a number which you
can sort of get in your head.
So let's try writing.
Let's pull out one of the one plus R's.
So it's minus one over one plus r times.
See Over one plus r plus two s
two CE over one plus r squared,
k plus t times c plus a hundred that's
the last payment over one plus r to the
t.
Now
what is that? Can you interpret
that? And the answer is yes,
you can interpret that because
what is that? That's saying?
These are all the payments you're getting
over the life of the bond paid cc and
the last one,
c plus a hundred.
This number that keeps coming in front
of them though is the year in which
you're getting the payment. This is in
the first year. I could put a one there.
This is the payment and the
second year there was a two here.
This is a payment and the teeth here,
there's a t here.
You got that t from taking the
derivative of the denominator here. Okay.
So it's like waiting the year in
which the payments come by the press,
the value of those payments.
So in the first year the value is see
the present value of c of one plus r and
the second year the payment is see
the value, you know, but discounted.
See Over one plus r
squared in the last year.
The total payment of c plus a hundred
but you have to discount it by one plus r
to the teeth.
So this is just like taking the average
year in which the present value flows
actually come.
If I divided this now by the
present value of the present value,
this number,
these numbers down here see over this
plus c over the squared plus one c plus a
hundred over this to the teeth.
Those are all weights multiplying
the year in which the payments come,
they add up to the present value.
So basically I've just got a weighted
average of what year the payments come in.
This is called the average life
is this thing in here is the average life
because I multiplied the year in which
the payments come by, the present value
of the cash flows there. And I'm going,
I've made bows multipliers add
up to one by dividing the up Pv.
So yeah, this is the, this in parenthesis,
all these terms are the things multiplying
the year in which the thing came.
So if I add up all these coefficients
here, I'm just getting the present value.
So now the coefficients add up to one.
So I'm just taking an average of the
year in which the thing cane and that's
what the average life is.
But that's equal to the,
to the derivative of the present
value divided by the present value.
Okay, so what's the percentage change in
the present value is the average year in
which the payments come.
So let's just think about it.
Suppose you have a 10 year
bond, it pays C, c, c, c, c,
and then a hundred at the very end. What
do you think the average life is? Well,
if there were no discounting,
the average life wouldn't be five because
it was such a huge payment. In the end.
The average life would be,
you know, eight or nine. Okay.
But there is this county,
so this thing at the end won't count as
much and the average life is probably
seven if it's a 30 year bond fee,
average life,
you know you're going to get CCC and then
all the way at the end you're going to
get c plus a hundred well, if the payments
were all equal and no discounting,
it would be 15 but there's a
huge amount of discounting.
So that last payment is
really pretty irrelevant.
So probably so it's not
clear which way it goes.
Probably the average life
will be less than 15 okay.
So, so you can see just
by looking at the bond,
I'm ending with this thought
by looking at the bond itself,
you can figure out what
the average life is. Okay.
So I've trader just by a little experience
and common sense can figure out the
average life I'm here, all the payments,
the way they're coming, they're coming,
you know, evenly across the whole history,
the bond with something at the end.
So the average life is probably
a little bit over the average,
but if you go way off,
you pushed the final payment too far to
the end that it's becoming negligible,
it's almost irrelevant.
And so the average life by discounting
probably be before the average.
So a 10 year bond probably
has an average life of seven.
A 30 year bond maybe has an average life
of 12 or 13 once you know the average
life,
you just have to,
to hold bonds in proportion
to their average life.
The dollar amount you put in each bond
to hedge it is just proportional to its
average life. So that's how a trader,
without having to do any arithmetic,
can kind of guess how much of the 30
year bond will it take to hedge a 10 year
bond.
And how much of uh,
so which has the so which has a higher
average life. The longer the bond,
the higher the average life, the
more sensitive it is to, uh, uh,
to interest rate changes. So the less
of it you need to hedge your position.
So if you hold the 30 year bond,
you don't have to hold that much of it,
a sixth of it. In order to hedge this
mortgage, the mortgage has a very short,
average life because it's
prepaying so quickly,
so it's not going to last very long.
So it's this amazing connection between
average life and sensitivity to interest
rate.
Average life is something you can guess.
Sensitivity to interest rate is something
you have to do huge calculations for.
But the two are almost the same.
Okay. So on the problem set,
we'll see if you can do it.
Um,
I ask you a couple of problems
to do with the average life.